we spent it's no exaggeration years in a
room myself our executive producer at
marvel studios Trent Tran Joan Anthony
Russo and our screenwriters Chris Marcus
and Steve McFeely
years in a room working on infinity war
and endgame and one of the fun games was
we had character cards that were spread
around a table that were up on
whiteboards and deciding who was gonna
go at the end and who was gonna who is
gonna turn to dust how's it going
everybody it's Warren and Avengers
infinity war it was such an amazing
movie as we all know and it was so
exciting to see so many different heroes
come together in one movie and then
sadly we had to watch half of them turn
to dust
[Music]
and although Marvel has tried to keep us
in the dark about pretty much everything
in regards to Avengers in game we know
that it's going to be about The Avengers
who are left trying to undo the snap and
bring everybody back but still we have
all been wondering what we can further
expect from Avengers in game will time
travel be involved will alternate
realities be involved and who are going
to be the main people there are still
many characters that are left and there
are some new very powerful characters
coming into play in avengers endgame as
well such as Captain Marvel Captain
Marvel is said to be so strong that she
is going to be the most powerful
character in the MCU and will lead the
Avengers moving forward and face for so
with so many characters in one movie and
amia remind you that there's a huge
rumor about a scene where we see over 20
heroes at the same time so with so many
characters and incredibly powerful
characters entering into Avengers in
game and Avengers in game wrapping up
the story arc from the first 10 years
many people have been wondering and many
people have been worried that Avengers
in game won't do the original Avengers
justice I know many people have been
worried and many people have asked me
about this but for those of you who have
been worried no need to worry anymore
and this is not coming from me it's
coming directly from the president of
Marvel Studios Kevin Feige in a recent
interview with Rotten Tomatoes Kevin
Feige
has confirmed that Avengers in-game will
mostly be about the original six
Avengers who would fan oh who would be
in that 50 percent pile and it they
moved around a little bit but for the
most part it was what you saw at the end
of the movie is is what we had
determined early on in large part
because it would be the most
heartbreaking seeing T'Challa go right
after his first appearance seeing
spider-man go and Peter Parker after
that relationship had been established
between he and Tony Stark and it also
was designed to leave behind the
original Avengers because then game very
much follows their story so again for
those of you worried that Avengers in
game will not do the original Avengers
justice no need to worry anymore yes
there will be other characters in the
movie and yes these characters will play
specific important parts Kevin Feige
even slightly addressed this with
Captain Marvel in the interview before
they had been exposed to these
intergalactic conflicts and bringing
Carol Danvers into the into the world
and understand where she came from where
she has been and as we head into another
movie we have later the summer see her
her grand return so what Kevin Feige is
saying is that there's a very specific
purpose for bringing Captain Marvel into
Avengers endgame she's been exposed to
intergalactic conflict which is
basically what in game is about Thanos
has pretty much waged war against the
entire universe and of course giving her
origin that we will learn about when
Captain Marvel comes out and given her
ability to time travel that we learned
about thanks to samuel l.jackson she
will play her part an important part in
Avengers in game but other characters
will play their parts as well ant-man
war machine Pepper Potts rocket they'll
all have very specific roles but the
movie will primarily be about the
original six Avengers and that's coming
from Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios himself so we know that they'll
all reunite at some point and come
together to figure out a way to defeat
Thanos so that's it for what Kevin Feige
had to say about in game being about the
original six Avengers let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below and don't forget I'm still
doing my giveaway if you'd like to
interfere your chance to win five imax
tickets so you and some friends can go
see Avengers
game in IMAX all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts in your favorite superhero or
villain and of course don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]